[Music]  broadsword you're gonna have two handed  sword oh we're going to try to strike  your opponent five times you can block  if you hold down the zr button or ZL  button you can guard so if your  opponent's doing a vertical strike hold  horizontally and guard i want to see a  death animation from you guys so strike  vertically really quickly we go it's  probably gonna be easier if you use this  dual handed just because it's going to  you'll make more what would i say like  that exact thought well yeah exactly  no case is like a ninja sword you're not  that's kind of slice it up it's more  deliberate in there I know sword  Christmas got this one  so cross swords by holding down okay you  guys are you guys are in go  keep going all right keep down the  Krista you do it are you doing officer  yeah you got two hearts are back Oh keep  going no don't hit him either you're  getting too close  replays here you guys actually had some  really good  [Applause]  [Music]